it's a fool a Capcom exclusive power
98.3 where hip-hop Liz man bootleg can't
hold it down with the homie right here
we got that big dog Kendrick Lamar I
want to talk to you about the owl you
drop's the same week as Taylor Swift
yeah like I don't like 1.2 million or
something crazy we gotta get hip hop
back to that haha cuz she wont dont
records boy you really yeah really had
that crazy those crazy debut numbers man
what were you expecting like what we're
like some realistic numbers are you're
expecting this I know a lot of people
were a little surprised yeah um probably
like 210 somewhere around there but you
know what happened was the album a drop
and then the same thing that's been
having with my no career since day one
just word of mouth you know you start
seeing little small reviews and people
started talking about and just telling
the next person to go get it and with
that being said you know that sugars
down to another few thousands and the
next day another four guys unless
they're right yeah then you know becomes
one of the biggest day buttes since um
thing traits for some yeah yes plays big
deal yeah yeah how important i noticed
that on it seems like everyone that was
on that club paradise tour uh-huh it's
like doing major stuff you of course I
mean that rocky F in problems join a
psychic the whole lineup on that's early
you know what I'm saying how important
was was that tour like you know some
time now that
been since you were on the tour our
report was that toward you and like you
don't worry about right now that was a
great advantage and I shout out Drake
every time for letting me see that you
know that type of atmosphere because
what happens is it warms you up you know
for us to come everybody want to get
bigger and want to get better and have a
broader audience but you know when you
get to level some might not know how to
control the audience you know and that's
a tough job to do you know they have you
know a renal full of people you know in
tune with every song every movement you
know so it was really like i wanna say
scrimmage you know by the time my next
album come around you know hopefully
I'll be at beyond that leagues right
like you gotta saw how out Drake did it
yeah yeah yeah its educational right
right right that's all another world
that's for something I want to talk to
you about this record we're just kind of
talking about it before before we do
this a jig is up record you did we say
cold yeah yeah yeah it was done in one
night it's about a few hours before it
came out few hours before congrats rock
yeah just spontaneous going to studio
and just you know have fun I know you
work all that stuff can we got stash box
at stash box a little stash box what I
mean listen I know you can get this
question all the time about j Cole
collateral man album realistically I
mean you guys aren't recording that
stuff for nothing you don't know not
know you guys are gonna surprise this
one day I think that's what it'll boil
down to nothing one day we're gonna lure
out it to build boys or a trade oranges
Kendrick yeah he got him he got his
album come right now which is incredible
he just dropped a single Miss America so
I know everybody wanted a frenzy for
that you know so we probably got to wait
how do you feel like you two were kind
of like that the leaders of this nuke is
more
about you know substance more than
anything you know what I'm saying about
having I mean of course be a dope ass
rappers hmm but also you don't say
something too yeah definitely you know
we take we take pride in that too you
know we take their responsibilities and
we showed it to our music you know
that's that's the whole point in the
whole ideal situation for us to continue
this this on this cultural hip hop that
actually has a full body of work not
just sporadic songs everywhere radios so
much hey how do you own balance doing
like the type of records that you're
known for doing and then happened on
ASAP rocky [__] problems and tearing
up Ali know something I mean which to me
I was a super underrated verse but ya
know it's more of like an ignorant more
clubs right really ever doing them songs
for a long time and and that's really I
think that's where it come from you know
yeah it's really not it's really not
even a balance is really just me I think
people just overlook that size of times
and you know that's it now of course
we're pals right now uh uh yourself in
game on the same stage yeah game has
really been having your back with the
whole shine situation has anything not
that he need to know me you know Vita
honey yeah yeah yeah you got to you got
to you know um that's game that's the
home have you had any communication with
shines into your since he publicly did
what he did no I haven't I'm yeah after
shower yeah yeah irrelevant shout the
Scheinman it's a good dude man it's real
good dude that's what's up hey I gotta
ask you um the girl who brought up
through yamaha Charice sure any a year
right I know I was gonna mess that up
sharain huh who is sharing where she had
no I don't know she rents that now you
know what she's in there she's in the
city somewhere maybe I wonder she know I
like that she is you know prevalent
throughout good kid maad city yeah she
yeah she's a promiscuous woman she's
let's say that will say that that's
what's up man two powerhouse 2012
Kendrick Lamar yes sir the album is out
good kid maad city I'd interviewed you I
don't normally say two to three months
ago right asking you know when Allen
comes out we would be saying about it
what is you know the feedback you
looking for now that it's out people are
calling it the classic yeah yeah and you
know I feel like that's fab think that's
fair but i think that you know i think
you said this thing 10 years ago people
so far as i stated they will be calling
classic yeah they definitely will be
because i went in the studio making sure
I didn't unless you know there's
something that's classic worthy by the
time it comes out so once again some
years about it then their know for sure
they'll be mad you know that the game
don't have that no more you know ten
years it'll be like man remember like
without we are with illmatic now exactly
exam he's a cargo mat and say this was
my last album and I won't ever put no
more albums out there appreciating a
little bit more even more but that being
said your studio recorded for potential
second hours and even on the horizon I
have a lot of material recorded you know
I don't start recording but know if I
won't get a second down for a while yeah
Kendrick Lamar things on I'm A through G
my girl every time always yep power 98.3
tower how hunted Hendrick is getting
our day